[Music]
and forgetful waiters News uh worse it
is our so much Olli when you're hungry
thank you submitted by Davis of chilled
L everything sure now he's not no teddy
bear smells
that's like sauce or anything you could
have said 25 oh come on now no no the
bear how greasy he looks so he's
thinking yeah here's a pop-up restaurant
is staffed entirely by waiters suffering
from dementia and Alzheimer's oh that's
cute is that fun you ever do it [ __ ]
awesome we're going to take your order
and [ __ ] forget that you even ordered
that is so no they're gonna sit there
and ask you your order oh my god that's
going to be crazy
while they're taking your order they're
going to forget what you ordered while
they're taking it and they're going to
ask you again it's going to be like so
you want the chicken okay what would you
like to have
oh you want the chicken okay would you
like what would you like to have it's
going to be like over it over and over
dude is not that extreme I guess I can
laugh about this because both my
grandparents had Alzheimer's and
dementia and hilarious
so my grandma probably guys my grandma
would ask me the same question within
like minutes yeah she'll be like oh so
are you are you a college student a lot
of know I work okay in the middle of a
conversation
so how school know I work right now all
is true cuz they remember you from a
specific period of time and that's it
and that's like the strongest me
discipline grandpa to come back in this
[ __ ] look at me how'd you get so
big bro like I thought my live with the
dude and he was coming every day because
you're so big and you're like Pat me on
my butt like I'm alone carry [ __ ] up to
you no but here's the fucked-up part
though so one time I came back from LA
went to Sacramento this when he was
alive I was like oh hello I'll grab
let's meet your grandson he goes oh my
god you're so huge and I walk into my
room and I just here this will go who's
the fat guy like oh you [ __ ]
I'm gonna [ __ ] you up you son of a [ __ ]
ha ha ha here you go who's the fat guy
Mike what the hell huh talk [ __ ] back
yeah so there's this restaurant even my
name is so cute so the name of this
restaurant is called forget-me-nots
rejected ah that's clever order again
the restaurant of order mr. come again
what mistakes the restaurant of order
images oh so depressed you wanna come in
yeah welcome to the ice skating rink the
right way I thought his restaurant oh
yeah it's not a butterfly hmm
this is gonna be the fun his restaurant
ever well where is it up so this isn't
Tokyo oh [ __ ] yeah that's like the wrong
place to have it it's like super
efficient yeah and no one want this like
well this is a pop-up restaurant so it
was only open for two days and they're
saying that good business no it was just
a little like pop-up shop to really um
to change perspectives on people with
dementia and Alzheimer's to normalize it
a little more as if people could be more
understanding of what these people go
through can just teach customers to be
more patient so I'm gonna show you guys
some photos yeah I mean like I feel it
in work they're [ __ ] cute so cute
you know awk with that fresh ground
pepper grab Burke do you know the menu
I'm so curious it's more Deadpool it's
whatever they want okay
just this photos okay what if they bring
out the food and forget which table to
give it that is happening so they're
saying that not the patrons are like
they're not really complaining to
obviously
what if they forget where they are and
they go fishing in the toilet that's my
grandma my mom my grandma was like hey
grandma
oh yeah I want that for uh for I think
like Chinese knee or something and then
as a respect like I got a red envelope
prepared and I put money in their nose I
hate and I got my knee hey grandma happy
new year this is your grandson I want to
give you some allowance and ashes like
oh thank you for the biscuit it's just
hard to putting the money in her mouth
and I'm like no no grabbing some money
and she's like okay a jezzer hat
sideways for some reason this is like a
hip-hop look if I saw she put did you
put it away
she almost ate the money though that's
all I'm an easy dude
would you tell your mom like why the
[ __ ] I have to give grandma money she's
gonna eat it eat it so depending on how
far gone they are I feel like my grandma
[ __ ] yeah that seems like pretty far
gone they're probably not gonna employ
your grandmother they might have been
denied her application [ __ ] she probably
ate is is pretty gone but she like her
mind is sharp like she can pretend that
she knows what the [ __ ] is going on
she'll never admit that you're like
she's wrong you're always wrong what's
an example well like for one is my mom
keeps telling her you keep asking him
the same question and she goes no it's
the first time I asked of shut up yes
she was she's out of it about her
severed asparagus and then so she
forgets that she's eating chocolate like
we got her a whole thing of these candy
because she loves that old people candy
you know and the she pretty much
finished like candy she finished like
80% of that whole entire box in good
city yeah is she going to shark that's a
lot of [ __ ] we're just talking and then
she's just eating her chocolate and
she's offering me chocolate every minute
would you like a piece of chocolate
[ __ ] I brought you that chocolate oh
you did say she ate that much she must
have been doing Cartman loves chocolate
dude but she just keeps eating it and
then could she forget like she's not
taking her pill I mean she she forgets
that she already took the pill or should
he forget like she ate lunch and then
she'll eat again it's crazy
Wow Alzheimer's good my grandpa's don't
think all his friends are alive is [ __ ]
when he was alive
homey they all dead like in 97 you
outlived all those [ __ ] dude
Wow winning that at my grandma's funeral
I was like hey like worse was hard would
you like a friend but I'd like William a
friend that's what Bill did he opened
all of them doing under years old oh
that's right I forgot about that [ __ ]
because they remember the fondest
moments of their life and with you so
like for me too she thinks I'm a six
year old five year old boy yeah and she
thinks she's still married she's been
divorced for over 30 years
oh wow yeah she's like when my husband
comes back he's off from work he's
always working but when he comes back
we're going to go out to this place this
resort all this I'm all like you crazy
my graph I went nobody coming to get you
[ __ ] you're always talking about what
you get upset my crap would get upset he
goes yes attached to any people because
I would tell my friends to pick me up
we're gonna go to LA and my mom's like
if I did we're gonna go to a like
anything else worried that no your dad
my mom savages [ __ ] there she goes how's
that possible they're all dead
well that's where you get it from them
to him but it doesn't know he doesn't
know well at least he knows where he's
at like you know that he's not in LA
yeah he knows that he straight-up exact
of murder and it will try to call ball
this ghost homie this crazy i'ma tell my
mommy to pick me up we're going to have
a boys road trip so shut up
pop I could miss that little dude visits
you at night for sure oh I'm pretty sure
he does and he laughs at you yeah so
this pop-up restaurant will reopen near
September 21st which is the world
Alzheimer's day oh that's really cool I
wish I did that out here because um the
only exposure I've had to that is his
grandma and his grandma
gone gone though she was a comedian I
like how like the it's funny because my
grandma she has a very strong
personality so even though her mind is
gone she believes in what she believes
and she doesn't second-guess it one time
I went to uh this one big-ass temple
and like how you guys been to the temple
in Hacienda Heights yeah it's [ __ ]
huge right so the headquarters of that
in Taiwan is like five times bigger than
that place so imagine like being at the
Vatican City which is humongous right
and my grandma were coming downstairs
from the restaurant and she was like I
know a shortcut
and I'm like how the [ __ ] do you know
this is the first time we came in and
she starts going across imagine like the
[ __ ] Vatican City or something huge
is like the doors here somewhere the
doors here somewhere and then if you
were to zoom all the way out it's like
the Great Wall of China and although the
doors here somewhere that don't look
like what the bug and she was so
stubborn that when we try to pull it
away she thought we're trying to ruin
her plans Wow yeah I'm like my grandma
you're on a wall there's no doors
there's no shortcuts the shear studio so
you guys are sold
how long do their memory last are like
for that it's like short-timers I think
it's already beyond that she's just
tripping up it's actually for what
happens what happens it's act is the
best for them right when they wake up Oh
their memory yeah it'd be best that's
what everything as fresh as the day goes
on and they get more tired it's ten
times progressively worse they just keep
napping down here because I had to take
care of my grandpa so like in the
morning he was good like he started
remember certain things conversation was
fine towards the end healing a ninja
turtle so it was just like this whole
thing but in the morning he was like oh
my grandma she was she thought I was a
substitute teacher a person I was coming
over to clean the pipes here anybody but
her grandson that's crazy did you know
at what age she remember you by like
when you also didn't remember is it
Noelle memories is just like completely
completely mixed up is it hereditary I
think it's like michigo because it asked
me dude who [ __ ] us can we [ __ ] woody
did we all have all these videos to look
back on and then actually look at won't
even recognize myself I know I'll be so
funny that's like a severe Alzheimer's
looks like what my that's what my
grandma had but she couldn't remember
anybody at all yeah yeah what if my
grandma still remembers me it's been
about a year since I've seen her now
both of both my grand
fathers they passed away before like I
can even really talk to them and then my
grandma's are still still alive and they
still have pretty good memory so they
don't have also know they know I
wouldn't mind having like dementia that
when I'm a little older I want to think
whoever the [ __ ] I am when I'm like
90-something
and I still think I'm a [ __ ]
three-year-old doing [ __ ] comfortably
[ __ ] that's dope I don't want to know
like the disparity of it's frustrating
that it seemed like it was very
frustrating I would want happy dementia
because you are not the not the homeless
dementia you know like if your world
could either be hell or it could be a
dream Wonderland so you could becoming
like you could wake up and it's like oh
my god the best dream ever or it could
be like there's a nightmare yeah and you
can't control it you're like living in a
trapped like dream world i but I'm for
real though I'd never want to go to this
restaurant you'll piss me off Simon to
support the ladies I just give some
money money trying to like go there and
be like get your order on and they're
like please no cilantro and they put
like a bowl full of cilantro here you go
and it's like [ __ ] talking about like
someone that went to this restaurant and
she had order like the steak and then
they brought her in gyoza gyoza like I
wanted to take action you never know
what you're gonna get yeah just a
mystery restaurant dude that's pretty
kind of cool I mean you've got to go on
with the open mind yeah exactly yeah
whatever kind of thunk though you
ordered like a [ __ ] $30 steak and you
got $5 yo that I think you got a paper
route
what if they forget the tab to they
ended up fixing it for that lady but
that's pretty funny nuff said so fiv
hey guys I hope you enjoyed that episode
of just kidding News and if there's a
story that you guys want us to talk
about go ahead down into our description
box below and there's a link there where
you can submit articles for the next
video click right up here
you
[Music]